yes and so then I brought her back and
that was like the first series that took
off and it was kind of like a system
where I would do the show and then the
girls that were kind of like huh like
the wheels were turning I would take
them back and then show them like a red
pill content creators yeah stuff so well
I mean I guess Jordan Peterson isn't
like red pill red but they use that word
for so many different things yeah yeah
the thing with Jordan Peterson is he he
evokes he invokes evolutionary
psychology a lot and that's why you put
him in that category yeah and also like
again we're skipping ahead you discussed
before about
um Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson
talking about an attack on masculinity
right right and you're a big fan of
Jordan Peterson yeah I am do you do you
feel can you describe like how you think
that works because I I feel the same way
uh where there's an attack on just the
concept like I don't think there's such
thing as toxic Maxi linear I think
they're toxic people yeah they can be
masculine or feminine but when a seal
team is coming to rescue me from another
country I want those [__] to be
masculine as [__] right I don't care
about their toxicness do you uh do you
do you feel like there's an attack yeah
well I actually had like sort of a red
pill moment when I was listening to like
one of Rolo streams and he was talking
about how like the the masculine way of
doing things is always considered wrong
okay and I was and I was thinking about
it and I was like it's the same way
they'll say oh you need to open up
emotionally to men but that's not how
men process emotions and so like what I
realized I was like oh my gosh like the
masculine way of doing things is always
wrong and I mean before that I always
knew it I mean in a way because it's
like you have all these girls saying men
are trash men are the problem like but
that's like the basic talking point like
when you really peel it down I was like
that is so interesting
um I think what it is is the when men do
things in a masculine manner it doesn't
feel right okay again when you when you
use the example of the burning building
or storming Normandy then the masculine
way is right it doesn't matter how you
feel about it but when it comes to like
I have this conversation again with when
I talk to some of my female friends or
my girlfriend but we're having a
conversation I'm like you're listening
to the words I'm saying and then you're
looking for an additional meaning what
I'm saying but I mean exactly the words
I'm saying there's nothing additional
just the words I'm saying there's
nothing else and they're like but why
are you so mad at me I'm like no you
didn't hear what I just said I'm not mad
at you what's going on is I'm saying
words what the truth is exactly the
words I'm saying but you're like looking
for my hand movement and my eye
inflection yeah we do and there's
nothing going on and it's so hard and
like especially for me with women I work
with and women when I'm on a date before
I've gotten this relationship it was one
of these things where like I need to be
able to trust you the only way I can
trust you is if I say I'm gonna be here
at this time time and you understand
there's no additional meaning it doesn't
mean I'm going to be here at this time
and [__] you I'm mad at you it just
means I'm gonna be here at this time if
you can't just literally listen to the
words that I'm saying and understand the
literal meaning we can't accomplish
things yeah and that's the thing that's
so scary to me which is why we get into
the the 304s go over here right and then
the men you work with are over here
because we're getting off topic here but
one of the things that always bothers me
is
because I'll have feminists on the show
and I have a lot of my female friends in
La usually they're feminists and we'll
have this discussion I'll be like you
want to be taken more seriously in the
workplace let's say specifically science
technology engineering and Mathematics
okay and then when you do so when I ask
you how you picked who you dated you
started quoting astrology
[Laughter]
supposed to take you serious ly right
is that what I'm saying yeah yeah so
again again one of my uh one of my
friends she was uh uh interviewing me
for um a financial Network for
tastytrade
and and while she's interviewing me
Vanetta Logan and she's interviewing me
and she's like this is why women need to
be taken more seriously in this
workplace and then she says I don't sign
a contract when Mercury is in retrograde
and I'm like do you not understand the
problem there it's like you don't
understand regular physics it's okay to
believe in astrology as like a fun thing
yeah it's like watching when I watch the
Hulk Hogan Fight The Ultimate Warrior I
knew it wasn't real they don't really
hate each other right they probably swap
wives and get steroids from the same
person they're not actually hating each
other the problem is when people start
thinking Sagittarius is real Libra is a
real thing but then I'm supposed like
you want me to take you more seriously
how am I supposed to take you more
seriously when I'm asking you to read
the evolution of Desire but you're
quoting the five love languages to me
right you see what I'm saying I'm asking
you to read why beautiful people have
more daughters but you're quoting sperm
Wars to me or you're you're talking
about something you read in 50 Shades of
Gray how do I when I'm when I'm giving
you objective facts and you're quoting
back to me how you feel about something
I don't know how to have a conversation
it's by the way everything I just said
that goes for Holocaust deniers flat
earthers and uh and and just anyone else
who's people who deny the moon landing
like they're not using reality or any
sort of reason to get into their their
Viewpoint so I can't use logic or reason
to get them out of it and that's that's
one of the difficulties I found yeah but
yeah I mean that's the main one is is
like when I hear people say I want to be
taken more seriously in a certain field
and I'm like but you still believe in
nonsense you still buy lottery tickets
yeah the flat earthers are interesting I
was like I kind of wanted to talk to
some of them okay I know what do you
want to know oh I just to know why they
think the Earth is flat like you ready
okay I did four hours a four hour debate
oh gosh okay so what they believe is
what's called empiricism and basically
the world is what I see okay anything
that is outside of what I see is
probably not true so the idea of quantum
mechanics isn't real okay right the I
the the concept of gravity because I
can't see a graviton it's not real and
so they what they do is they make the
world basically be what it looks like if
you look at the world from a as a six
foot tall person standing in the middle
of a desert it looks flat it looks like
you're on a flat plane but the reality
is the planet that you're on is 24 900
miles around okay and so because it's
that big you can't see the curvature in
it one of the things Buzz Aldrin said
when he landed on the moon is he said I
could actually see the curvature of the
Moon because it was so much smaller than
the earth does that make sense I could
see the Horizon the literal Horizon of
of land Beyond
so what happens is what flat earthers
believe is that like this whole thing
was a conspiracy and you'll notice
there's a lot of uh anti anti-semitic
stuff in here there's a lot of um
Rothschild Illuminati they're protecting
you NASA is part of this Global cabal
conspiracy to hide the truth from you
and whenever you try to produce any kind
of evidence to counter that all the
photos are faked really all of them are
faked uh they use CGI in 1969 no that's
not true do you think any of the photos
were faked no what happens is this do
you know how to use the panoramic view
on your phone yeah okay what happens
when you use the panoramic view what
happens is the AI in your phone starts
taking all the photos the multiple
photos it takes and then it matches them
up together right that is called a
composite on NASA's website because
sometimes you can't have the focal
length work to take the picture of an
object 20 like 8 000 miles across you
have to use a composite of multiple
photos to get a photograph of the earth
do you understand yeah because the photo
is a composite flat earthers then say
it's faked faked is not a composite is
not faked zirko what's going on that's
his name right I definitely I definitely
want to go out is that which means yeah
well you gotta explain this you're the
flat earth guy it's the photos aren't
fake now he's just gonna say they're
fake he's not gonna provide any evidence
that they're fake he's just being
satisfied he's gonna say why is it that
the flatter symbol is the same one as
the United Nations and I'm like no dude
that's not evidence people don't
understand when people say evidence
whenever I have a feeling about
something it's like isn't that a
coincidence a coincidence is not
evidence right they'll say it's evidence
does that make sense I'll give you real
quick when you next time you talk to
zerko these three things they won't be
able to counter them number one when I'm
standing in Buenos Aires when I'm
standing in Sydney and what I'm saying
in Santiago I'm sorry Buenos Aires
Sydney and when I'm standing in
Johannesburg When I Look to the South I
see the Southern Cross when I'm in
Nevada I can't see the Southern Cross
because I'm in this I'm in the northern
hemisphere when I look in the same
direction in Johannesburg yeah South
when I look in Sydney South and when I
look in
um uh or uh some what is it Buenos Aires
South I see the same object if the Earth
is flat in those three areas I should be
looking in three different directions
because the Earth is flat but it's not
because I'm looking at the same object
the Southern Cross because the Earth is
round it's unequivocal proof that the
Earth is round that's the end of the
discussion okay the second one is if I
look at the Moon flat earthers believe
that the Moon is four thousand miles
away well the Moon is four thousand
miles away if you do simple trigonometry
if I'm standing in the tip of the
Southern uh South America and I'm
standing in Alaska I should see a
different face of the moon right because
it's only four thousand miles away but I
see the same face of the Moon all the
time because it's 38 000 miles away
because the Earth isn't flat and the
Moon is a sphere or it's a it's an
oblate spheroid OP oblong spheroid
whatever it's called oblate spheroid so
that's the reason why that's the second
unequivocal proof that the Earth is
round and then the third one is I used
to fly for the US Military and if the
Earth was was flat a trip to go from
South Africa to uh South America would
take like 20 hours because it spreads
yeah does it make sense but it doesn't
take seven hours yeah so what they're
saying is the retort to that is no it's
because you're flying faster than the
speed of sound and I'm like no I'm in a
747. I can't fly as faster than the
speed of sound and they just make up
this nonsense those three proofs but
here's the number one proof the absolute
unequivocal proof that would not only
landed on the moon I guess can I guess
what is it is it the the time like the
sun is like time changing no no okay
okay Nikita Khrushchev congratulated the
United States for landing on the moon
oh think about it
so he's he's lying that the United
States landed on the moon they were they
were literally willing to go to nuclear
war with us but they're going to lie
that we went to the moon like that's
that's the main did they ever land on
the moon no no no no no no other humans
landed on moon from any other countries
just the 12 men from the United States
there were six six things I don't know
much about space travel yeah I just yeah
no we can get it like
if he wants to go into like the event
yeah come to Vegas
the Van Allen belt nonsense like all
these stuff there's answers for all of
it it's just the thing is like the
Holocaust denial and Flat Earth the
reason why I go after these two
specifically is because they can't exist
if you take any time to look at the
other point of view if you look for
reasons why the Earth is round you
understand why the Earth isn't flat and
if you look at reasons why there were
six million Jews that died during the
Holocaust you can't come to any other
conclusion that six million Jews died in
the Holocaust because there were nine
million Jews before the war and there
were three million Jews after the war
they didn't just vanish they didn't
aliens didn't take them off they'd end
up in the United States they weren't in
prison camps in Russia they just
non-existed anymore Nick you gotta come
on too but but here's my favorite part
here's my favorite one again during the
during the Nuremberg trials when they
asked the Nazis none of them denied that
there was a holocaust
none of them there was no Holocaust
deniers until the 1980s yeah just not
because it was 40 years and so many of
those people
you know I'm not going to explain his
point of view because I've had enough
but yeah Nick you gotta come on no for
sure yeah yeah no problem
the problem is again I'm not making a
judgment about any of the other stuff
right is there a One World Government
that's not my point the point is when
you believe in these things you're doing
so because you will not you're not
allowing yourself to even look at the
other point of view are you a deep State
believer
um listen I work for the federal
government like no they're morons like
okay the real answer is so boring Pearl
people hate the real answer you don't
you don't think there's like a globalist
agenda depopulation no here's the
problem like if you really understood
how stupid people get at the federal
level you would never believe this [__]
like it's so I did see it a bit in
Corporate America yeah that's not the
that's not the federal yeah but like I I
flew for the military for seven years
and like we were flying airplanes that
were built in 1957. yeah in order for us
to get a [__] the paperwork we had to
fill out to get a new pencil you're
telling me there's some globalist
conspiracy no are there a few rich
people who have like really bad agendas
[__] yes of course yeah but this idea
that it's just like like two things can
be true right Hillary Clinton would have
been a [__] horrible president and
she doesn't eat babies those two like do
you think do you think she was killed do
you think you believe her body list or
whatever she's killing everybody
um
a lot of people have died around I don't
actually I don't actually have an
opinion on it his thing
yeah they are fine but they're but like
the problem is they're fun but then what
is feminism like you called you said
feminism was a hate group right you
remember said that yeah but like do you
understand how it's like we want them to
understand the truth but then it's okay
to believe in Flat Earth do you see how
that's kind of like hypocritical yeah
you understand what I'm saying we're
using empirical data to show yeah when a
woman cheats in a marriage 83 of the
time she picks a new partner right
that's a really good piece of
information but when I explain to a flat
earther that's a retro reflector in the
Sea of Tranquility and we go shine a
[__] laser the beam come back in 1.1
seconds or 2.2 seconds which irrevocably
undefined I'm sorry proves that there is
a retro reflector up there and we landed
on the moon that all sudden that
evidence is thrown out but the evidence
that women cheat is not thrown out it's
like you believe in the evidence when it
supports your cause but not when it
doesn't I'm for the evidence in all
cases so that's the thing if red pill is
a derivative of evolutionary psychology
then let's believe this the science then
but then we can also believe in the
science it doesn't mean that there can't
be additional signs but the point is
like it's like we want to believe the
truth when it comes to male female
Dynamics but we don't want to believe
the truth when it comes to [__] what
happened during World War II that's
stupid I just think that's hypocritical
this is my point okay sorry we're
getting off topic here
um I do want to Hillary Clinton's body
list though yes no uh I don't think that
she intentionally is asking people to
kill other people do I believe that
there's somebody in their organization
that may have like may have done
something like this possibly there's a
lot of people you're right but like do I
think that so for instance let's just
say the people who believe that um the
the wrecks the election was stolen if
you think that Joe Biden is sitting in a
room just like pointing out different
places where the election is stolen as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible